because they'll they will just
ask more and more they will take an inch
and then there will be two inches and
then all of a sudden you know you're in
a different place than you were before
can you explain that a little bit like
what what is something right I started
off with really innocent type of
Productions like Wizard of Oz you know
Beauty and the Beast but even a Beauty
and the Beast you know they were drawing
on cleavage lines on my chest at 14 and
stuffing our bras and having us wear you
know three bras to make sure that we
looked
you get a chance to have a professional
actor in your mid so we thought we'd
invite Ashley to come on board and help
us understand some things about acting
because we actually get a lot of
questions people wanting to go to
Hollywood you know wanted to do acting
for a living and if you if you've seen
enough of our videos you might know our
perspective on that but yeah hopefully
this will generate a conversation a
little bit about
um just acting in general so welcome
Ashley thank you glad to be here
so do you guys have any uh experience in
this field I did some extra work a
little bit and so that was a lot of a
lot of fun but um you've probably had
more experience than that than I have
well actually I never did any extra work
I actually started off in a performing
arts school when I was five years old my
parents sent me there and so I took
drama and music classes every day and my
Drama teacher actually sent a letter
home to my parents saying hey this girl
has some talent I really want her to be
in this production that I'm directing
it's a local community college
production but it's a well-known
playwright it's Dale Wasserman and so he
did some films some plays and it was
actually the first time that this show
was ever being produced it was called
the stallion hell as a part of a series
called open Secrets and so because I was
the first person to ever play this role
my name is actually written in the
script which you can see on the screen
as well so that was when I was eight
years old and that was my first paid
position so you went from straight from
drama like High School drama to acting
and you skip the whole extra thing you
skipped the whole hey I'm trying to get
in let me give my comp card out and pray
I get into this thing and you skip that
whole thing right it wasn't something
that I ever really intentionally went
toward I was really young at the time I
was only eight when they invited me to
be a part of this production and so
after that I thought wow you know maybe
this is what I can do with my life I was
eight years old thinking yeah Someday
I'm gonna be an actress for real you
know something professional and so right
you brought up your a well how was your
parents reaction to this like they're
like okay maybe put School in the
background and put her full we hear a
lot of stories about actresses when they
actors and actresses when they start
young and their parents are like oh
there's some money here
put them in now you're the breadwinner
of the house so where's your parents
reaction my parents are very supportive
so this is something that I seem to
enjoy but they didn't get too
star-crazed about it so they just kind
of supported my ambitions where I was
and so from there I just continued to do
theater production after theater
production in the school and outside of
the school and Community Productions so
the time so did you go from the drama
and didn't mean to interrupt you but you
went from The High School drama did you
go into theater actual theater like you
went and did that theater over and over
again for a long time and then you went
into yes I simultaneously I was doing
school productions and then Productions
all over the valley in Arizona where I'm
from and so by the time I was 15 in some
of the local Productions around the
valley I was nominated and I won an
Arizona award and that was a really huge
deal it's kind of like the Oscars of
Arizona acting and theater and so you
can see some photos here from that
ceremony as well no I imagine being this
close to Los Angeles I mean it's only a
couple overdrive I think if I remember
correctly you you you probably have a
lot of people that pull Talent from
local areas there so you know there's
Scouts and people that will go all over
to these things and you know you
probably were getting pulled maybe
potentially same you know you need to go
to LA or New York right I can't tell you
how many people were kind of fooling me
in that direction telling me hey you've
got something special you know I think
that you can really have a future in
this and so I put a lot of stock into
this I mean it was hours and hours of
time and dedication I devoted my whole
life to being the best actress I could
possibly be now here's something that's
interesting because I I went to Los
Angeles I spent about six years trying
to chase this whole acting career and
um you know going to countless auditions
and uh you know carrying around a little
headshot of yourself like your picnic
place
you you nerd out on your own looks
what's unique about me and and it's like
I can see why people become maybe you
didn't start out so much as as like so
self-focused but it's like the business
makes you and creates you to be like
that because you're just trying to sell
yourself constantly absolutely that's so
true I can think back to that time and
directors were always saying you never
know who might be in the audience you
know you got to put on your best face
you're going to put on your best
performance and so we're always thinking
yeah somebody's gonna Scout us at this
performance but you know things like
that they dangle the carrot well they
always did that yeah yeah did your
Christianity ever make it hard for you
to go with certain roles you're like I
don't care I'm trying to make it
anything just let me try I think by the
time I landed in Los Angeles
um I had known somebody that is still an
actress today and and she's been in
quite a few movies and worked with quite
a few of the top directors and I because
I knew her personally it was like I was
that close to it you know it's like I
can achieve what she was achieving and I
was in high school plays with her when
we when we got there so I think it like
you get this real false sense that you
two can do this but when I actually
really think back on my experience I
think there's a lot of steps that she
maybe potentially took to get there that
I at this point am so glad I did not
take those steps but I probably would
have if it was offered in that way and
so I think I got shielded from really uh
compromising too much of myself and
that's what I feel like the people that
really do generally make it there I mean
by the time they are an A-list name
they've compromised quite a bit to get
to that position absolutely it does
require a lot of compromise and more and
more compromise as you go on at first it
doesn't seem like you're compromising
much but then it becomes a slippery
slope because they will they will just
ask more and more they will take an inch
and then there will be two inches and
then all of a sudden you know you're in
a different place than you were before
can you explain that a little bit uh
like what what is something I started
off with really innocent type of
Productions like Wizard of Oz you know
Beauty and the Beast but even a beating
the Beast you know they were drawing on
cleavage lines on my chest at 14 and
stuffing our bras and having us wear you
know three bras to make sure that we
looked
I know I know that's just crazy to think
about but that is the reality of it
you've seen enough the little Iceberg
you know this this is probably going way
deeper than what we could even Explore
in this one but uh you've seen what
child stars deal with going into this
business and it's awful and when I hear
stories like this it's just like yep
it's so true that's exactly how they
treat them and I can see that that would
be the direction I would be heading if I
were to continue in this path and so
even by the time I was 17 I was in a
production where I was playing a
daughter who was supposed to be filming
sex scenes in the other room on her
webcam and so I just remember thinking
how did I go from being in the Emerald
City to now I'm playing this this role
where I'm filming supposed to be filming
sex scenes in the background so
that was quite a big leap but it took a
while to get there I by the time I was
in high school I was president of the
thespian society when I was graduating I
was heavily involved in choir and
singing as well and so I had an offer
from New Mexico or State University for
their vocal performance program and they
were wanting me to get involved with the
Santa Fe Opera and things like that but
something else happened during that time
that really radically shifted my life
and changed my perspective
what was that Christ came into my life
and gave it to my heart amen and so can
you tell us a little bit about that
story I mean yeah maybe I can give you
some background on kind of my family
history and what led me there so my
parents have an interesting background
because my dad is actually part of a
prominent Mormon family and so my entire
doubts out of the family is part of the
Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day
Saints and my mom's side of the family
has a little bit of Adventist background
Seventh-day Adventist and so my
grandfather was converted and then kind
of taught my mom a bit but then she
never was baptized and kind of was
discouraged actually from being baptized
by somebody in her family who said oh
you're not ready yet and so if you're
not ready yet she kind of was never
ready she she wondered if she would ever
be ready you know so it's two vastly
different backgrounds completely
different as opposite as you could
possibly expect did you understand or
know a little bit about both or did you
kind of just a little bit
um my mom definitely had more influence
in my life because she's a stay-at-home
mom praised the Lord that she could stay
home and raise me but well interestingly
it was almost like I was an only child
even though I have three older brothers
because we're so far apart in age
actually my oldest brother is 17 years
older than me so I kind of had a unique
experience where I do have older
siblings I'm kind of like an only child
but also I kind of like I have younger
siblings as well because they started
having kids by the time I was five years
old and so being that I was the only
child living at home I had a lot of
individual time with Mom and so she
would try her best you know teach me
some principles from the Bible and I
kind of had a somewhat Adventist
influence you know like oh we should
keep the Sabbath but as a child to me
that was more of a restriction of
something that I was like which I'm sure
is very difficult in the theater world
because your performance your your
weekend warrior in that point exactly
you have to begin to compromise even
from that compromised immediately it
wasn't a difficulty for me because I was
just thinking you know this is what I
want to be doing and
um
unfortunately I followed my heart in
that way and I wonder how you got that
idea ugh I know right we
were hard there's no
way maybe it's time to start following
your heart
[Music]
once and follow your heart
nothing is impossible if you follow your
heart
a lovely story
[Music]
and give her the courage to follow her
heart your only duty is to the emperor
but I have another duty to my heart your
duty was to stay home but your heart
told you to break the rules how did you
decide between Duty and harm by
following my feelings I wound up doing
the right thing I guess I learned that
my duty is to my heart
[Music]
[Applause]
the rest of the world may follow the
rules but I must follow my heart
Disney on Ice presents follow your heart
I was watching all those movies and TV
shows
and um let's see so I I had kind of a
confusing divided home growing up I dad
worked a lot but I he would send over
Mormon missionaries to our home and you
know I just was very confused about what
reality was and so I kind of just didn't
fully Embrace either one
and so I didn't really have a firm
foundation for Morality or what my life
should be based on and so by the time
that I was invited to be involved in
theater
I just went completely for it I I
nothing no hesitation and and it's an
interesting world because you do get
asked to do these very immoral things
that you almost wouldn't do in real life
but you're just playing a character and
my character does that you know and and
so it's like you'll kind of like
rationalize it in your mind as well as
like oh well that's that's okay for me
to do that exactly and in many cases
it's seen it's honorable right like I
think of Heath Ledger who as you may
remember he played uh the Joker in The
Dark Knights and you might remember that
he had a tragic end to his life after
his serious commitment to his character
I mean he would lock himself in his
hotel room for weeks on end with little
to no sleep and he would be drawing
crazy pictures and making crazy notes in
this diary
and there's darks right dark things that
you would expect from somebody who's
going through serious mental illness and
what happened is a lot of people are
skeptical you know did he kill himself
or not but his last words and his diary
were bye-bye hmm
and a lot of his castmates would often
say that he threw himself on the walls
in the set just to make his injuries
look more realistic for his character
wow and so I think that that is the
level of commitment that every actor and
actress aspires to even in the small
scale Productions I was part of I mean
we took ourselves very seriously yeah he
was a method actor and he actually
um would show up on set if I if I'm if I
remember this correctly
um would not break character yes and and
in fact I remember reading articles with
the other cast members that were on this
character and said he was downright
scary when he would show up you just
felt like this dark presence that was
with him my one experience with Heath
um on the film was are seen together in
the hospital bed which is really my only
scene with them and
it was
um I was in the hospital bed that day
and I thought well I don't really have
any lines what am I going to do and I
had no idea what was going to happen so
I was
got in the bed and they were lighting
and Chris was walking around and doing
things and then Heath came around and
Heath was always in character
so he would come around and you know be
talking to himself in the corner
like this
and then he would come up I was laying
there and I was watching him the whole
time
and he came up and would walk around me
like this
and I would watch him and I would watch
him he'd walk around the hospital bed
like this I'd watch him didn't say
anything for maybe an hour he would walk
around
and then we'd watch him and then he'd
start saying his lines and I would watch
him boom watch him come around to bed
like this and then all of a sudden my
hips would go up like this and he capped
caught my hand
so we just went through this organic
process of developing this scene which
was really nothing
and then when we came time to shoot we
had this thing beautifully choreographed
and you know he did we never said a word
to each other wow yeah and then it was a
long day
and we walked out
um
to our back to our trailers and Heath
was here and I was walking and he puts
his hand on my shoulder and he goes
that's what acting's all about I think
you know I saw
um uh little pieces of evidence where
it's like he when he met with
Christopher Nolan and talked about doing
this performance he said I have a trick
up my sleeve and you know there's
there's lots of videos of Christopher
Nolan talking about this experience but
he called him like what is it that you
have and I honestly think that he was
messing around with invoking spirits and
he pulled something inside of him that
literally made him go insane that's
interesting that you bring that up
because I was actually taught the same
method that he used in his acting it's
called the stanislavski method
and basically to sum it up it's the art
of experiencing and so it really
recommends that you become one with your
character essentially my directors would
constantly tell us things like invite
your character in empty yourself
wow and let your character live out
their life in you I took an acting class
that was uh centered around this kind of
theology or this kind of theology the
the method and um what was very
interesting was he would have us
actually come into the class and we
would do actions that we would do on a
daily basis like let's say just taking a
shower so you shower if you ever paid
attention to your showering in a very
sequential order that you pretty much do
every single day then he would disrupt
that and he'd say you need to now have
your character shower and you need to
let that character shower like he would
shower anyway they would do wacky things
like this so that it was like basically
training your brain to like stop being
you and be this other person it's really
uh I think opening doors it would be
wrong to think that those type of
methodologies and all of that is at the
high level because we've seen interviews
who was it when Will Smith asked uh for
some
guidance from Denzel Washington I
believe it was he said that same exact
thing let uh it wasn't Muhammad Ali yeah
it was Muhammad Ali he was going to play
Ali he told him to to go and pray right
but this is at all levels and it's wrong
on all levels and
um that someone might view this with
Heath Heath Ledger as an extreme case
but there are other cases we talked
about Michael B Jordan and how he it was
hard for him to disassociate from
killmonger so it was no real plan I
didn't have a I didn't have an Escape
Plan either you know I wanted to be in
this lonely place as long as I could in
order to kind of capture the essence of
what Eric you know Stevens was what
killmonger was so when we wrapped the
film you know I'm like in my mind I was
like okay cool go back to you know
regular left get back to LA and be cool
but it was a little tough for me at
first to kind of like it's hard just to
lay him down and be done with it yeah
how did it take you a while it took me
it took me you know I mean I don't
really know exactly when I came out of
it but you know I went to therapy you
know I'm saying I started talking to
people started unpacking a little bit
there's a man who played Elvis even to
this day is still talking with the
accents of Elvis he can't remember who
he was before he totally immersed
himself into that character and lastly
Elvis Presley himself you were an icon
and a rebel and I love you so much Irene
Bartlett Austin's voice coach recently
chatted with Australia's ABC Gold Coast
on Monday and she addressed how the
actor's voice permanently changed since
playing such an iconic role to telling
the outlet because of covid shutdowns he
was working on it all the time and it's
difficult to switch off something you've
spent so much focus and time on Irene
continued on defending her students
technique and said it wasn't being done
for show adding what you saw in that
2023 Golden Globe speech that's him it's
genuine it's not put on I feel sorry
people are saying that you know it's
still acting but he's actually taken the
voice on board I don't know how long
that will last or if it's going to be
there forever Jim Carrey has a very or
had a very difficult time stopping being
what was the comedian that he played
um
Andy Kaufman in fact when he played the
Grinch he would not show up some days
and and Ron Howard would be like hey
dude are you going to come to work you
know everybody's out here with the
lights on and everything and he'd say
well uh Jim Carrey's not here and he'd
be like well who's there and he'd be
like Andy Kaufman well will you please
send Andy Kaufman out to do the scene
and literally he do the scene is Andy
Kaufman when when Man in the Moon came
out there was all this talk about the
process that you went through when you
became Andy Kaufman essential did you
ever have it in the back your mind back
then that you wanted to share that story
in this way that you're getting to do
now yeah and I thought I thought I had
become Andy Kaufman but there was no me
actually at the end of it all I realized
that there was you know that this
character was making choices to play a
character and uh you know so that's what
kind of happened and that's what Chris
found in this interview and in this
footage that there was actually a
existential not a crisis but a discovery
going on you know because he couldn't
stop like there was there was a blurred
line between where he began and the
character he just played yeah I remember
Jim Carrey going out to that that one
show and saying who are we really I
don't even know who I am I I don't know
what is what is Jim Carrey I can relate
to that so much there were so many times
throughout my childhood that I thought I
actually don't even have a clue who I am
I'm all these other people but who is
Ashley and I couldn't answer that it was
actually kind of scary that that's
socially acceptable actually we're
playing millions of dollars for people
to do this but if it were to happen to
like say the average person they'll be
committed yeah right all these different
personalities exactly and you don't know
who you are I think that's why when
Johnny Depp was being interviewed by
Larry King and he was like it's a
strange thing for an adult to do this
kind of a job I mean you know you're not
Henry VIII you know you go back to your
trailer man you're you right you're
pretending that you're this other
character but interestingly when you're
going through the motions and you're
saying the words and you're living the
life of that character your brain
doesn't know the difference right by
beholding we become changed but we're
not just beholding we are living coming
out their life yeah and there are many
times where directors would say things
like pray to the theater Gods you know
invite them to come to you and give you
the energy that you need to do with
performance did they identify who
exactly those are or it was just this
Collective theater Collective okay yes
does any of them have any and this is
probably way off have any type of altars
or any type of thing that they had set
up in their own little uh maybe their
own little trailer maybe their own maybe
a separate Corner I've heard about this
happening throughout history we're not
just in acting but even in uh some
well-known uh heists that have happened
these uh I read a story just the other
day about these these uh bank robbers
they had set up this
alter and they believed it gave them
special privilege to go get this money
and when they would go out they were
finally able to stop these guys and this
is this is I realized there's a little
bit of Rabbit Trail but I'm coming back
they were able to stop these guys
because they finally figured out where
their car was
and they ended up being able to shoot
all the FBI by going around in the
circle and one guy was able to stop them
because he shot them
uh in the neck but they found out that
all the FBI had riddled them through
with bullets but these guys kept going
one even went through the aorta but
these they kept going and kept and they
shot several uh it's a horrible story
and but it's a well-known documentary
story where they went back they said how
are these guys able to do this and the
documented case in Florida from Miami
says that these guys were able to do
this because they had an altar and they
were praying to these gods of War those
deputies were able to tell me that the
only thing they found the only thing
they found at this um at this place was
they found a little altar
that was a Norse a pagan sort of Norse
god Altar and it appeared that uh these
two individuals had at that time they
did some kind of sacrifice to uh to some
uh evil spirits uh from the Norse
mythology there was something to do with
Berserker spirits and so
so I I told them I said that's it that's
how they did what they did they did some
kind of sacrifice and these uh these uh
whatever was the god of Mischief that
they did these uh sacrifices too uh I
think was called loci Loki and uh to the
Berserker spirits and they were given
these Berserker Spirits whatever they
are they were given that in order to
accomplish what they did and that's
that's what they did they had a complete
dedication uh on a spiritual level that
inhabited them came to them and helped
them to do these extraordinary Feats
that they did Loki and specifically
interesting and uh they said they had
some spiritualism that had something to
do with it and they they closed the case
as a paranormal case so it was
interesting but there is something
spiritual that was that is absolutely
inside and that can happen to actors and
you can't deny it absolutely yeah the
entire theater is just filled with
spiritualism sure
and I think of the verse John 17 21
which says when Jesus prayed that they
may all be one as you father are in me
and I in you and that they also may be
one in us that the world may believe
that you sent me so it's Christ that
wants us to be one with him that's right
and if there's anything else that we're
trying to be one with then I think
that's very problematic yeah so so I'm
glad you brought that up because you
started to tell us about this moment
that you had this huge Paradigm Shift of
reality and and Jesus came into your
life and in a mighty way um what what
happened to your desire to continue in
acting at this point uh well you know
another one of the issues in theater is
just the sensuality that encompasses
everything I kind of mentioned that with
like the drawing on of the cleavage and
everything but often we would be off
stage and having to make quick scene
changes and you gotta change clothes
quick and so you don't care who's around
you're just taking off your clothes and
you're changing to a different outfit
and so you know there's people around
you they're they're doing showmances you
may have heard of the term before but
basically it's like you fall in love
during the show or you think you're in
love and then it lasts for a while and
then it's over and then it's like the
everybody had these show answers all the
time you know somebody's making out with
somebody or somebody was caught up in
the catwalk and they're doing things
that they shouldn't be doing and it was
just it wasn't even just the kids it was
the adults I mean there were times when
there was a family of people that were
involved in the theater and the parents
were doing their production and the kids
were doing theirs and the parents were
found in the in the back room you know
having a good time but the kids were
there listening and so
if the environment was just very
pervasive with sexuality and coming from
my background
um I had actually experienced sexual
assault when I was very young and so
going into theater and the sensuality of
that world just kind of drove me even
deeper I know a lot of people respond
differently to sexual assault they
either will Retreat and not want
anything to do with with sensuality or
they will kind of delve into it and in
my case the theater world made it just
too easy to delve into it because the
everything was just about the way that
you look the way that you present
yourself and so I would often as I'm
questioning who I am I was often
questioning am I worth anything you know
because it was always based on what I
could bring to the table or what I
looked like and there's always somebody
that's up and coming there's always
somebody that's doing better or looking
better and so I thought what can I do to
be good enough and I think that my
perception of who God must be was
actually that way as well I think we
often look at God through this lens of
whatever we think love is and whatever
our experience of love has been and so
my experience of love not only from the
assault and from the relationships was
um a faulty picture of love it was an
abusive and toxic picture of love and it
was a picture of love that required that
I be good enough or do something that
would make me a good enough person in
order to be loved but
over time I learned that God knows who I
am exactly and he loves me anyway and
that is just the most profound truth
that changed me completely you know
you're exactly right because I just read
a story about a character that was in
that that old show that's old now it's
it's called
um stranger things and she was a a
well-known prominent I think cheerleader
on the program and she says she was uh
assaulted sexually and she says I don't
want to have anything to do with acting
anymore I'm done with it one of the last
movies I did one of the producers asked
me to
like he hired a girl that was he was
sleeping with and then he had her ask me
to have a threesome with them
so like that's my boss and uh so this is
a very common occurrence yeah friends of
mine had talked about this girls I'm
sure are subjected to this even at a
higher level than even guys are but I
mean the casting couch do you keep
climbing up that ladder you've got a
plethora of dirty men that would love to
you know oh yeah you know just just
abuse people and so it's a it's a it's a
difficult world to navigate I think as a
as a girl you know there there's a big
Power imbalance as well and it's like if
these people are lording over them when
we saw it with the whole metoo movement
right how many people
fell sir you know pray to to saying well
if you want to move up a level you got
to go through you know Harvey Weinstein
or whatever and that's that's just a
common thing so you know
I also hear this this you know people
that get abused and and like in your
case you know it's kind of like a magnet
instead of being repulsed by it
um you know I really wonder if the devil
does that or he's you know hand-picking
people that are really severely like
kicked off of damaged yeah damaged and
then it's like you're gonna you're gonna
not turn away from it you know so praise
God that Jesus got a hold of you and
amen you know was able to flip your your
understanding around yes I could see
that after time I could see that I was
destined for destruction and you can
kind of even see in some of my pictures
here the sort of outfits that I'd be
wearing and shows and the types of
things I'd be involved in
um wow
a lot of different characters there yeah
and and and you know it's like this is a
little family that you you you know you
get go from job to job to job I mean
that's kind of how it is in the acting
world you meet these people and it's
like oh hey we're doing another you know
proud product or our production over
here and so it's like you know you kind
of rub shoulders with a lot of people
who also are struggling with their you
know moral compass and
exactly
so it just makes it all the more easy to
just go into that Temptation that's all
around you
but God was also really reaching out to
me throughout this time as well because
throughout all these experiences I just
really felt my need of a change I just
felt my need of something in my life and
God divinely orchestrated different
events in my life to help bring me to
him for instance I was supposed to go on
this date with a guide to the state fair
and he stood me up and so I had these
tickets and I said well I'm just gonna
go with my parents instead praise the
Lord I went that day because as we were
leaving the state fair there was a man
handing out these DVDs
and there were DVDs from a Ministry you
may be familiar with amazing discoveries
and this was like back in the day like
10 years ago and so there's this this
whole series total Onslaught and I just
go home and pop it in the DVD player and
Mom and I are sitting there just love it
like what what is this one after another
after another we just consumed them we
just could not get enough and I just
remember thinking I
feel like I'm going through a complete
paradigm shift for my perspective of
what the world is about right now and I
was probably 16 or 17 at the time
thinking I don't know what to do with
this but I just went on to YouTube and
just continued to look for more and more
and that's actually how I found your
guys Ministry Little Light Studios like
original back in the day I watched
Battlefield Hollywood wow an oldie but
goodie an oldie but goodie yes but that
really touched me and impressed me that
these things not only the theater that I
was personally involved in in my life
but also the things that I was consuming
watching the movies and the TV shows and
the music that I was listening to I mean
I remember a specific part of
Battlefield Hollywood which was like the
social experiment that you were showing
where they're driving through town and
then there's these posters around with
these funny faces on them and they they
asked the guys to draw a picture and
it's literally the exact picture that
they see that they had seen on the
posters and I'm thinking if that can
impact her mind so much
right you're not even intentionally
looking for it then what about the
things that I am intentionally focusing
my time on and so I honestly at that
point I just threw out all my DVDs got
rid of a bunch of CDs I got rid of
everything and I said I don't even want
this influence in my life anymore I knew
that God was pulling on my heart and
asking me to make a decision because
at this time also my brother had started
to go to church God reached his heart he
went to a series of meetings
Evangelistic meetings and he gave his
heart to Christ and he was baptized and
throughout all this time I know that he
was praying for me he didn't even know
what I was going through
but he was praying and
he decided to invite me to church
many times throughout the years you know
sometimes I said no sometimes I said yes
but then he really got in his mind I'm
gonna invite my sister to come and sing
which is the perfect entering wedge for
this theater nerd right no oh okay you
know she likes to sing let's get her in
church to sing and so I said sure
and my brother is a talented pianist and
so he played and he stood up in front of
the church and said I have been praying
for this day you don't know for how long
I've been praying for my sister to come
to church and to come and sing at church
that's awesome and that that really
touched me that he would share that in
front of the church and I thought
there's got to be something that's
keeping him here
there's gonna be something that's
changed his life I mean he stopped
drinking he wasn't like a heavy drinker
or anything he's just a social drinker
but
um he just seemed different and I wanted
to figure out what that was that made
him seem like his life was in a more
peaceful and happy place
and so um my brother actually played a
really big role I went to church just as
I was the clothes
the skimpy clothes the hair the makeup
all of it the jewelry even the boyfriend
the the toxic boyfriend that I was with
at the time
and they loved me as I was which was
huge for me because I know a lot of
people say you know am I going to be
judged when I go to the church I was
worried about that as well
I was already what are they going to
think about me I have I literally know
nothing about the Bible maybe very
minimal
but I was worried that I would be judged
for my lack of knowledge on the Bible
but really people just wanted to pray
with me and pray for me and help me to
move forward
so so I have a question because
and you can correct me if I'm wrong but
it sounds like you made this really big
decision to get rid of DVDs and really
change your life before you had a
commitment to Christ it was because you
were seeing all the wrong things that
were in it so for someone who may have
done that step
you know each story is different like
some people can quit let's say alcohol
cold turkey others have
um Temptations ongoing so after making
that big decision what kept you
committed to that decision without
saying Oh but you know there's a theater
play happening where I got this
invitation what kept you so solid
without even having a commitment to
fully give your heart to Jesus yet that
is an excellent question so it was
around this time that I also felt
convicted about the theater right
because I because my brother invited me
to church I started reading the Bible
and as I'm reading the Bible I'm reading
all these verses about how you cannot
serve God yeah and Mammon yeah and how
you can't serve two masters and how God
is calling us out of the world and how
the world is going to pass away and I
could just feel God speaking to my heart
the world is going to pass away and if
you hold on to it you are going to pass
away with it
and to be honest it's like you know if
if you kind of get close enough to what
we're all you know all the actors are
trying to achieve you start to really
question like why are these people
miserable
you have what I'm trying to get right
and yet you you're happy you're not
happy why are you not happy and I think
that deep down inside that real
satisfaction and that real happiness
truly comes from a relationship with
Jesus nothing else can fill that amen so
the second that you get that little
taste of that you're like I want more I
want more and and I love the story that
Jesus Takes you as you are and you don't
have to you know clean up before you
come see who comes to me I will know why
is cast out yeah and and that's a
beautiful thing that that your church
you know that you were beginning to
attend you know didn't Hammer you think
about how many people's experiences when
they first walk into the church and
they're like what's she doing here yeah
take the earrings out you know what I
mean and then all of a sudden it's like
you you you might not come back and look
at look at what happened because nobody
did do that to you exactly just kind of
loved you back in that relationship so I
think we we also have to Shepherd those
that are coming back in and not be so
you know hard on them of course God
wants you to to make changes in your
life I don't think you should come into
the church and remain the same exactly
he never leaves us where we are yeah but
but I think we can leave room for
helping those individuals alone
there's a message there I love it
challenge me no no I'm agreeing but the
thought came to mind because there's a
message of you know when someone comes
into your congregation and they look
different from whatever you're used to
yes approach them prayerfully accept
them
you know be that light that or the sign
that leads them directly to Christ what
would you say though to those churches
um that have the mentality of we need to
have theater night in our church to
attract certain people or you know we
need to keep the youth in the church and
so let's put on these programs that
are not good
or we see the outcome or what is
demanded of the people in that world in
in the world but we're trying to
christianize it somehow in the church is
it even possible to do that should it be
done I I think it's a really delicate
balance like you know we're so wanting
to have these attraction tools to bring
people into the church where as I I
responded to the truth and and I kind of
shared Ashley's same experience of like
I didn't really have people around me
that uh I sort of baby stepped into the
situation I just myself was like like I
want more and I was hungry and I was
diving into it and and sort of like just
ended up along the way
um and I understand you know there's
there's some people that maybe are more
slow cookers and they need those baby
steps along the way but I think
sometimes we we mistreat our youth that
we need to entertain them into a
relationship with Jesus
and Jesus is enough yeah you know I I
just I think we need to be very careful
of not trying to make everything just
look so close to the world to bring him
in so so my testimony uh coming back
into the church is it has a lot to do
with with that I have a youth pastor
when I was uh not in the same state I
mean now way back out in Hawaii uh and I
was going every Friday night I would be
out and we'd be at the you know every
terrible place you can imagine out there
with me with friends and he would call
me up and say hey we're gonna have game
night hey we're gonna have a movie night
hey we're gonna have all these things
one attracted me and while these all
these things were good and I liked the
way his method and how he was doing this
that's not what attracted me back to the
church it was it attracted me back to a
church club and to have a bunch of
friends there and so I came back in and
I walked back into the church and I I
communicated with all these people that
helped a little bit but did it attract
me to the Bible and did it attract me to
to to want to have that committed
relationship with God
possibly not what really solidified it
for me was when I was with those friends
and this is where you can kind of make
the argument that hey you got to get the
people back into the crowd that helps
you when I was with those friends that
were committed to Christ they would
challenge me and say well can you tell
me where that is in the Bible and uh are
you are you sure that's that's the way
you should live Brad then I was
committed to say I'm going to prove you
wrong I'm going to show you from the
Bible where where I believe this is
found and I had to go read the Bible for
myself I had to go and make that
relationship with God myself and that is
what brought me brought me back to the
church that's what had made that
relationship with Christ so do games and
movie nights and all this worldly
activity and bringing that into the
church create Christians I don't think
so I don't think so at all but um I
think that we can go out and and make
friends with the world and bring them
into us we don't necessarily have to
bring the world to them yeah and I
always find it like sort of like a bait
and switch because on the one hand you
I'll use theater as an example you have
a theater event and you have all these
theater heads as you call it come and
come into the church just to turn around
and say hey you can't really involve
yourself in that anymore you're like
wait but that's what brought me into
search to begin with and that's not
really familiar because the lifestyle
that is in that world isn't in line with
the Bible isn't in line with
Christianity so it it would it's kind of
messed up in my opinion too you use that
Avenue to bring someone and only to end
up saying actually this is not according
to our beliefs then why is it to begin
with be separate you know yes I mean
would you go to a dance club that you're
dancing to Christian music you know most
dancing is very provocative right and
you would think like nah this just
doesn't really go together those two
concepts so I think sometimes we blend
kind Concepts together that you know
absolutely and like I was saying earlier
Jesus truly is enough like I mentioned
when we behold we become change and that
can be For Better or For Worse but when
it's for better we're beholding Christ
and when we behold Christ we're changed
more into his image and so all the
jewelry the the clothes the makeup all
that stuff that naturally shifted over
time as Ivy held Christ and he changed
me from inside out
and so there was a time when I said I
need to cut ties with theater I quit
every show that I was in I was right in
the middle of a production and that was
like the worst thing you could possibly
do they were like
you know we're never gonna hire her for
anything ever again she just put
everything and I said that's the risk
I'm willing to take I just don't even
want to be involved in this I want to
surrender everything to God right now
and
um I think it was a lot easier to take
the girl out of the theater than to take
the theater out of the girl right so
it's been a process of really
sanctifying me over time God has been
working on my heart he's still working
on my heart but he brought me out and he
delivered me from a life that surely
would have led down the same type of
path that Heath Ledger and many other
actors and actresses new struggle on
that's a really relatable thing to say
can you share some of the things that
you have done or are doing now to help
you in that process of taking the
theater out of the girl
yes well I think I'm a strong believer
in give them something better
and so I really think that if you fill
your time with things that are more
worthy of your time and attention and
things that pass the Philippians 4 8
test right I think that that's a good
um Way Forward for anybody who might be
watching as well who might be wondering
you know should I be involved in this
production or should I be involved in
this project you know I know God has
given me these talents for acting or
singing or whatever it might be that God
has blessed you with I truly believe
that all good gifts are from God and he
gives us gifts for a reason and I think
that they can be used for his honor and
glory and they can be used to witness to
people they can be used to bring the
truth of the beautiful truth of the
Gospel to those who so desperately need
hope in Christ
and so we really need to when we're
faced with something like that just ask
ourselves is this in line with God's
word is this in line with Philippians 4
verse 8 right and I think that that can
be our guiding tool as we try to move
forward right because you might say oh
Wallace just Wizard of Oz but that was
my beginning
yeah it's wise advice
um you know for anybody that is uh uh
you know in the throes of figuring out
what you're doing for life and you're
trying to navigate this uh you know
maybe artistic gift that God has given
to you that is very wise advice we can
give you our opinion we can share with
you our experience but at the end of the
day our opinion does not matter in the
grand scheme of things God's opinion
matters and so the the the person that
you really want to go to and labor that
with is with God go to God and say hey
is this is this what you're asking of me
to do you know how you said you would
direct my past to go to the right or to
the left so show me which way you want
me to go and I guarantee you he will not
ignore you and just like you came to the
position that you were like I can no
longer do this I can't stand on this
ground you know I'm sure that that was
that was a prayer I prayed that prayer I
remember when I decided to leave like
God do you do you what do you want me to
do right and what is your will yeah and
I I had a creative like I wanted to make
Creative Media projects so God didn't
just take it from me and say okay no
longer can you do this thing over here
anymore he traded it and he said I'm you
used to do this for you and for your
glorification now I'm going to let you
do this for my glorification I still
Tinker with video all day long I do what
I absolutely love I'm challenged I'm I'm
driven by this kind of stuff and I feel
very satisfied that I'm doing it but now
it's not for my glory it's to turn
people and go consider this relationship
with Jesus and and I think that makes
all the difference in the world so you
you have actually turned your efforts to
music making yes that's been my
experience completely too God always
gives us something better his thoughts
and his ways are so much higher than
ours so much better I thought that I had
my life planned out for how it was going
to be I was going to be on Broadway or
whatever it was you know but he was like
um no yeah I have something way way
better than you're planning for your
life you just great and so I really held
on to that hope I really held on to the
promise in Jeremiah 29 11. I have a
future and a hope for you Ashley
and so I I had that in mind and I
thought Lord I don't even know what that
looks like but I want to trust you with
that
and so I think something that I realized
too is a lot of times when we're
involved in these creative projects or
anything like that we're we're reaching
out for something that is really a truly
a god-given desire we are
God has planted eternity in the human
heart we're grasping for that but we're
grasping for it in the wrong things
and so I think that God can always give
us something better and I truly found
something better in Christ everything
that I was searching for love meaning
purpose true connection I found in
Christ and so knowing that Christ lived
and died for me I want to live for him
and so I want to turn my talents to
serving him honoring him glorifying him
and so I started a music Ministry with
my brother and our two friends Ashley
Snowden music
I shared some photos here from some of
our recent engagements but that's
something how God goes above and beyond
to answer prayer not only amen did he
get you in church to sing now there's a
whole Ministry with the two of you yes
and it's brought me closer to my brother
than ever oh it's beautiful and it's
it's been a wonderful blessed journey I
feel more at peace than I have ever felt
in my life even in the midst of Trials
and that's really the amazing thing that
when we have Christ with us we can get
through anything he is he is continuing
to work on us he's continuing to give us
the strength that we need to make it
through anything
and I'm so grateful to be a part of this
I'm so grateful to be part of this
ministry and I've been honored to sit
here and talk with you guys and share
part of my story today and amen thank
you for sharing with us and coming on
our show
you know we hope you guys will check out
Ashley's uh musical talents that God has
gifted her and her brother music is such
a beautiful and and neat thing to when
you intertwine it with the work of God
like why do we play music before we hear
an impactful sermon because it opens up
the heart music in itself is a sermon
and so you know Ashley's out there
preaching literally you have been able
to turn those talents turn those
energies to God and we hope that you
guys will check it out
um thank you so much for coming on we
hope this was a beneficial conversation
for you please like this if you know
somebody who is thinking about going to
Hollywood maybe share with us with them
this video and hopefully this will give
them a a few things to think about do
some research we're not the only ones
that have come to this conclusion I
think that there are many examples of
people that have had training train
wreck lives going out there and trying
to uh you know make it in the
entertainment industry so please do some
research before you actually go out into
that world and of course leave a comment
we'd love to hear your thoughts about
what you think about what we just talked
about and um but thank you for watching
we'll see you guys next I know some of
you have been looking at Scotty's
t-shirt and Brad's t-shirts like oh that
is so cool can I get one of those where
can they get it okay you can go to
lightwear dot shops we believe in
wearing your witness no matter what you
do you are witnessing for for Christ or
for some other company so you might as
well you know share your light with
those around it may spark cool
conversation you never know and if you
believe this is a good conversation that
we need to have more of please follow us
go to patreon.com little eye Studios
you're the only reason we were able to
do this and you're able to push this
message out to more people so help us
out if that is you please visit us
patreon.com Little Live Studios all
right I think we can say goodbye now
thank you bye bye
thank you
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you